Bonjour, je m'appelle Jacques Joubert. Je
suis professeur de préhistoire
à l'Université de Bordeaux.
Nos travaux à Bruniquel ont permis
d'abord de dater des structures qui
étaient connues depuis les années 90. On est revenu sur ce site pour essayer de les
comprendre et de les interpréter, les
analyser et surtout de les dater.
Elles ont à peu près 180 000 ans. Et là, il y a trois conséquences majeures par rapport
à notre connaissance de Néandertal. D'abord, c'est l'appropriation du monde
souterrain par une humanité différente
des hommes modernes. Ça, c'est
complètement nouveau. Jusqu'à présent
c'était 35 000 ans avec les premières
grottes ornées d'Europe. Deuxième point
important : c'est la maintenance du feu,
parce que pour aller en milieu
souterrain à 330 mètres de l'entrée, il faut
être capable de maîtriser le feu et de
le maintenir avec des lampes ou des torches
portables. Et le troisième élément, ce
sont des structures relativement
complexes à aménager qui ont été
pensées selon un plan
avec un emprunt de matériaux choisis, bien
sélectionnés, des astuces architecturales,
et qui nous révèlent des structures
relativement complexes. Et pour cette
période, nous en avons très peu.